建议你去听听设计师的吐槽。
蓝苗的设计师在杂志反弹中提到过优异裤。
他说，他们给了我一本500页的技术手册，告诉我什么能做，什么不能做。
对于优异裤这个品牌来说，穿衣服它比较像是一套语言语法，
就是人人都能开口。
如果你是高手的话，你还能写诗。
感觉优异裤有意无意的，造了一个系统，这是一个非常宏大的框架，
就是比起做西京的衣服，甚至比坚持某种调行还要难。
Hello，欢迎收听余光Post。
这是一档关于品牌解析的播客，
从市场逻辑与文化美学两端出发，
一起探究那些真正打动过我们的品牌。
我是惠斯。
我是Jackie。
今天我们探讨的品牌是优异裤。
优异裤在我和Jackie的心目中是一个很神奇的品牌。
比如说，底腰的创意总监，
Johnathan Anderson,。
就是咱们比较熟悉的是他设计的罗易威的Puzzle Ball。
这个人呢，以drama的设计出拳，
但是他的私服总穿平平无奇的优异裤。
在比如小红书上优异裤穿搭这个话题，
笔记量超过了600万篇，
话题量仅仅次于OTD，
养活了上万个穿搭博主。
这件事有趣就有趣，
在以基础款注称了优异裤，
却成了穿搭的主战场。
上周张曼玉又入住了小红书，
他那条松齿感的视频被网友们一痛解析，
大家惊呼，
原来张曼玉也是优异裤女孩。
所以今天我们想探讨的就是，
优异裤是如何做到既出现在我们普通人的衣处里，
也能出现在设计师甚至是明星的衣处里，
他为什么可以贴地飞行价格亲民，
但天花板就这么高。
好了，话不多说，我们开始。
对，正好前几天我和朋友也聊到过有一哭，
就是这个朋友他是在巴黎某品牌工作，
他跟我说他们经常会遇到一个问题，
就是当模特全身穿的都是某个大牌的时候，
然后他们会进行拍摄嘛，
但是现场总是需要一些额外的基础款来搭配，
比如说一件白衬衫啊或者说一个黑的T-shirt这个样子，
但是对于他们来说可能最靠谱的这个选择呢，
就是去优异裤买，
因为它优质隐形而且特别方便随时都可以买到。
这个场景很像刚才提到的张曼玉入住小红书发的那支视频，
她身上的配饰都是DVN的项链啊，
姑娘的包，但是大面积的上衣裙子确实优异裤。
我觉得这其实说明了一个很有趣的点，
就是优异裤比我们认知中和时尚这个词可能是更紧密，
而且走的更深的，
它的基础款不仅仅是普通人衣柜里的那张安全牌，
而是在专业的时尚余境里，它也有一种万能接口的感觉，
就因为任何品牌的衣服都能和它对接，你不会觉得冲突。
就是有点像什么呢，像是那种可以提供常用接口的充电宝，
就是你无论充什么机子的，就是什么牌子的手机啊，
还是相机或者什么GoPro之类的，它都能解决。
在我们不太会关注的地方，有人在做这种总结整合升级，
那优异裤对于我来说就有点像是在做这件事的人。
没错，我和你的感觉很类似，优异裤的单品在我看来，
有点像乐高中的最基本的模块，
就是它单拿出来一块什么也不是，
但是通过组装人们能够获得巨大的快乐。
就细想下来，优异裤具备了一种少见的特质，就是高兼容性。
咱们不妨拿优异裤所谓的竞对品牌来举例，
看看它们的区别，比如说Cost，
就我知道Jackie很喜欢这个牌子，
跟优异裤一样，它也是单品极简的路子，
但是它主打剪裁，
就是它的型我有时候穿上就很挺拔高挑，
它有的时候就感觉自己套了个异形的马带，
有点不稳定。
对对对，它确实有时候是挺挑人的。
除了Cost，在比如说Zara，
我一进去，脑子里情不自禁就有一个信号会闪起来，
就是会问最近又流行什么了，
所以Zara的定位是什么，
它的定位是提供潮流的答案。
对，因为优异裤和Zara，
它确实是挺有意思的一对照的，
两个都是服装零售的巨头，
而且在财物上，这两个品牌其实经常会被拿来比较。
不过我觉得它俩应该算是平行竞争吧，
就因为虽然客群是比较相似的，
但是还是比较少有那种短冰相接的时候，
因为我觉得它俩的策略还是不太一样的，
就是可能是这个原因吧，
对，就是优异裤它提供的是规则，
结构而不是一个现成的造型，
所以对于优异裤这个品牌来说，
我觉得穿衣服它比较像是一套语言语法，
就是人人都能开口，
然后如果你是高手的话，你还能写诗这个样子。
哎呦，这个比喻很妙啊。
那如果我们说这个优异裤是语法型的品牌的话，
那Zara就刚才提到了，
它对于我来说就更像是句子型的品牌，
因为它可以快速的去复制梯台造型，
然后提供一个完整的句子给你，
它帮你就是把作业都抄好了给你吧，
抄好了抄好了，
但是如果说是优异裤和Zara这两个牌子，
就是为什么我说它俩其实是平行竞争的，
因为作为消费者的话，
我觉得还是挺乐意看到这种竞争方式的，
就通常这俩店它离的也不远，
然后你可以两边一起逛，两边一起选，
就我看到一个数据，
就是说很多人在当季去挑选衣服的时候，
他不会说在优异裤和Zara两边摇摆，
通常是两边一起买，
所以我会觉得它是一种平行竞争的关系。
哦，这么说确实是啊，
就是它可能会有不同的场景，
然后适配不同的品牌。
说回刚才，
你说优异裤它其实是一种愚法性品牌吗？
那你又提到了G字型的品牌，
你这是不是还得有个词汇型的品牌啊，Jacky？
词汇型品牌肯定有啊，
而且我觉得应该算是我们当下最熟悉的一种模式了。
比如说像上代来的小黑裙，
或者说是巴兰西亚尬的后底鞋，
然后当然这个也不是大牌的专属，
因为比如早年间比较火的，
框微的翻布鞋，
然后现在我们说的什么爆款啊，
什么之类的，
我觉得它都是一种词汇，
因为它提供的是强符号的一种单词感觉的东西，
而有的甚至是一种专有名词，
就是你可以用它来彰显身份的，
然后一般这种品牌呢，
就是需要有辨识度，
然后难以替代的那种感觉，
比如说你的一个限量包，
一个标志性的检查，
它其实都是你的，
怎么说你的穿搭当中的一个非常核心的关键单词。
涉到优衣库这种愚法性的品牌，
就是它具有这种不提供答案的特点，
关于这个特点，
创始人，优衣库的创始人叫刘景正，
他其实早有改过，
他说服装是生活的工具。
所以你的意思是，
他其实算是一种创始人基因？
对，确实就是，
品牌总是创始人意志的延伸嘛。
那他这个理念也不是凭空而来的，
而是通过一次失败或者的体会，
而这次失败的尝试，
刚好和Zara有关。
这么巧嘛，
就还真的是Zara？
对，是在2003年的时候，
Zara在日本大规模扩店，
当时Zara的门店数量，
虽然远远不及优衣库，
那个时候，
优衣库在东京已经有80多家店，
但七成是郊区店。
然后,
反观Zara,
他们的门店选址都在顶级的上圈，
他们的单店流水，
可以达到优衣库五家郊区店的总和。
所以那个时候，
看Zara的势头，
肯定是一个不可小区的对手啦。
虽然创始人担心的是，
Zara和优衣库的用户画像，
有高度的重合。
这个其实刚才你说的，
其实他们是平行竞争，
但那个时候，
创始人他不这么认为，
尤其当Zara，
刚刚启示的时候，
而且媒体这边，
也一直在放大这种竞争氛围，
当初Zara在东京开旗舰店的时候，
被日本媒体形容为，
欧洲时尚的降维打击，
总之吧，
优衣库在日本本土，
被迫迎战。
在2003年到2006年这个阶段，
优衣库就是在抵制Zara，
和仿制Zara之间反覆横挑。
创始人一边对媒体喊话说，
不做Zara,
但是另外一边，
这首暗线来了。
一直在2005年春夏，
优衣库室水推出了Wikli Uniclu，
模仿的就是Zara的策略，
每周上新，
大家听名字也能听得出来，
Wikli嘛。
它的风格也出现了。
像毛丁印花这样的元素。
毛丁啊，
这个我确实很难想象，
它能跟现在的话，
优衣库能出现毛丁这种联系。
对,
还挺有反差感。
反正当年室水的结果，
就是优衣库的Zara化，
沦为了四不像，
就是它技速度不够快，
没有Zara那么快，
它的设计不够潮，
而且库存还不够轻。
在2006年,
优衣库公司的财报，
披露了一条特别损失，
这条潮流线让优衣库交了。
50亿日元的学费，
果断关停。
我觉得可能也是因为这个策略，
不太适合日期，
因为我印象当中，
日本人不太擅长做这种事，
我觉得他们比较擅长的是，
怎么说，
就是把那些必须要很慢的事情，
尽量的做得快一点，
让它本来就做那种很快很快的东西，
跟我印象当中的日本企业，
是不太相符的。
说到这儿，
你知道优衣库这个集团，
它叫什么名字，
就是它的公司名，
不是这个品牌，
它中文叫讯销，
听起来不太朗朗上口，
不好记，
但是英文就是faster retailing，
就是快，
零售,
就是这两个词。
所以,
优衣库是有快这个基因的，
但是显然，
砸入了那种快法，
优衣库不太适合。
那这次失败，
让创始人意识到两点，
就是第一点，
日本企业很难在快速仿制，
欧洲潮流上超越砸，
另外就是潮流款，
它的生命周期很短，
整体上和日本消费者，
追求长效价值的习惯冲突，
现在之后，
它就决定放弃追逐潮流，
转向解决日常穿衣的实际问题，
那大方向呢，
就是我们现在头脑中的优衣库了。
优衣库后来，
它确认的这个方向，
总会让我联想到，
另外一个设计当中的概念，
就算是一曲同工吧，
就是被我们称作通用设计，
Universal Design,。
它的核心理念是，
当我们要去做一个设计的时候，
可能是一个物品，
也可能是一个空间建筑，
一个场景这样的东西，
那我们设计的原则是，
所有人都可以直接去使用，
不会发生某些人用不了的情况，
或者说，
要为了某一类人群，
还要去做额外的改良。
比如说呢？
比如说，
不方便行走的人，
我们去弄一个单独的入口，
加一个专用的升降机，
这个是无障碍设计，
它不是通用设计的理念，
而如果我们去提供一个，
所有人都可以走的坡道，
它很方便轮移使用，
但是它也适合散步，
适合拖着行李箱的旅行者，
还有步伐很小的那种，
小朋友，儿童，
而且甚至还有人可能会在上面，
去滑滑滑板啊，这种，
那这个就是无门槛的。
通用化设计的理念了。
所以也有一种说法，
就是说，
通用设计这个词，
它更好的一个称呼，
应该叫做泛用设计，
就是design for all这个主张。
所以说回来呢，
有一库，
我是觉得它是有这个特点的，
像我们刚才说，
它的门槛很低，
当然它上线又很高啊，
就无论是普通的消费者，
小孩，老年人，
还是说设计师，
其实你都是可以去买它的，
然后为了达到这个目的呢，
其实背后是需要默默的。
下很多功夫的，
而且我已经想当中，
这个思维，
应该在2000年左右，
已经生长在優衣库的品牌当中了，
我记得当年有一个，
它的宣传方向，
就类似于是男女老少都可以买的，
潮牌这个样子。
准确说，
優衣库在2006年，
差不多这个节点，
将它的品牌理念，
确定为made for all,。
就是互用你刚才说，
就design for all,。
还要包括它的这种，
它带给你的感觉嘛，
还有它的这个宣传口号，
它这个口号存续了小10年吧，
甚至现在还在一些新兴市场的国家使用。
对，而優衣库它做的，
不光是理念上的一些，
就是构想，
而实际上我觉得，
它是真的做到的，
我们可以举几个例子嘛，
比如说，
它,
第一个要做到的，
就是测重功能性，
解决需求，
像它最有名的那个，
hatec的那个系列，
就是那个面料的系列，
就是冬天谁都能感受到它的功能，
你不需要去懂潮流，
你有需求你就去买它，
它可以帮你解决就好了。
说到之后，
我想起来，
一个很有意思的单品，
就是2016年的时候，
優衣库出海东南亚嘛，
当年的报款单品，
是穆斯林防晒头巾。
大家知道，
印尼啊，
它是世界上最大的穆斯林国家，
人口有两亿多，
这个優衣库在印尼哦，
一年就能卖两百万个头巾，
就我想想那个头巾，
觉得就会很透气，
因为我夏天会穿
優衣库Arizam的。
透气杯Cirma，
就特别凉快，
我觉得優衣库的面料，
应当头巾这个场景，
一定很解决痛点，
真的是made for all,。
覆盖各种场景。
对,
就头巾这个品，
我觉得定的太厉害了，
对,
超级本土话，
对对对，
而且它除了材料，
其实还有其他的，
比如说它的色彩策略，
我觉得也是挺有学问的，
因为優衣库，
它是把颜色，
已经都给你研究好了，
不说单品有多出挑，
但是你不懂配色的话，
也不容易出错，
然后如果你是一个懂的人，
你就可以去拿它当做背景，
或者是用来增强氛围，
这种,
另外还有就是它的。
版型比例不极端，
这样的话就可以保证安全，
我们可以想象一下，
我们在優衣库的时候，
会不会问自己这个问题，
就是这件衣服我买回去能穿几次，
或者说我们什么时候才能穿上，
这件衣服，
什么场合才能穿上，
其实这种问题，
我觉得是比较少出现的，
就这种安全呢，
它又能使得優衣库的衣服，
能够相互搭配，
甚至和其他的品牌去进行混搭。
你刚才说的这个问题，
我完全觉得我花了好多钱，
我以后再试一遍，
多问问自己这个问题。
对，就是
made for all,。
designed for all,。
就说到这儿嘛，
感觉優衣库有意无意的，
走了一条比ZARA更难的路，
造了一个系统，
这是一个非常宏大的框架，
就是比起做西京的衣服，
甚至比坚持某种调行还要难。
是的,
是的，我非常同意，
所以我其实很好奇，
卉森你觉得優衣库，
它现在走的这条路，
是一开始就盘算好的吗？
这个太难了。
是一个好问题，
不过就是做这期播客也研究了一下，
就是我们可以拿
创始人刘景正的语路。
作为切口来回答这个问题，
他说,
優衣库不是突然变强的，
是每次失败后，
我们都在系统里加了一根钢筋，
優衣库的灵魂人物，
就是创始人刘景正，
他的个人风格，
就是那种危机中的铁血决策者，
他写了本资传，
资传的名字，
也特别体现他的形式风格，
叫一胜九败，
就是一次胜利，
九次失败，
就是優衣库衣服的风格，
可能让我们觉得他是安全的，
不出错的，
但是这家公司的真实商业之路，
却恰恰想反，
他是试错试出来的，
这错了也没事，
只要速断速决。
那这个你说的这种，
他是那种小心谨慎，
及时止损的那种试错，
还是真的能捅大楼子的。
就是優衣库，
他有待三四十年的品牌历史，
就是他中间的大时间很多，
就是失败的长时间多了去了，
这件事还得从创始人刘景正说起，
他这个人呢，
其实是个创二代，
1949年出生，
他爸爸也就是创一代，
经营的是一个定价昂贵的西装店，
他进公司之后呢，
形容自己的心情是，
他很像那些只想拉长途客人的出租车司机，
等待机会到来的时间总是很长。
就是他自传理理句话，
形容他当时的心情。
从他的形容中，
我们就能看出来，
他对他爸这个生意有两点不喜欢，
创二代不满创一代，
第一就是倒购是西装生意交易的核心，
第二就是西装生意周转慢，
用大白话说就是没多少人买，
刘景正作为独子，
接班之后没多久，
他就依然决然决定走向父亲的反面，
他决定要卖大众买得起的衣服，
就是休闲装。
他做了这个决定之后，
还特意去美国投资，
看美国人怎么卖休闲服，
他发现他自己最感兴趣的一种卖法，
就是美国的超市服装，
还有像GAP这样的舞蹈高卖场，
没错啊，GAP曾经是优衣库的老师，
虽然现在这个品牌，
我们都不怎么能见得到，
但是当时GAP的模式在日本真的还挺少见的。
对对对，我现在也会觉得，
优衣库的卖场是有点像那种超市，
或者说服装大仓的那种感觉，
就是他那出行，他特意学的。
好了，就是我们接着说回来，
就是到1984年，
优衣库1号店开业，
那他商品的定价，
大概是在1000多日元，
不到2000日元，
和当时的5美元，
就是相对比较便宜吧，
而且店里是没有倒购的，
只有店员，
这个和我们现在看到的优衣库店员一样，
感觉他们基本上是不说话的，
总在叠衣服。
那这个转型也很成功，
在价格之明，
1号店开业的第一天就盛况空前。
但是用现在的话来说，
我觉得其实对于消费者，
他是抓住了那个羊脸的，
但是对，
但是接下来他会有一个问题，
我觉得他的模式虽然成功了，
但是在之后，
如果持续的建形的这个过程当中，
他怎么能做到保持品牌价值，
然后不会沦为一种，
没有存在感的那种，
涉及白牌的呢？
哦，是，是，
会有这个问题。
这个优衣库感的接点很好，
就是时间来到了1998年，
相约98,
让优衣库一战成名的单品出现了，
就是摇利容外套，
就为什么说时间来的也好呢，
因为那几年刚好，
日本的天气，
他们会有预测说，
98年的冬天会特别的冷，
所以他们推出了这个摇利容外套，
但是,
摇利容并不是优衣库的发明，
就这种面料，
优衣库其实是以价格破坏者的形象出现的，
他当年直接把售价干成竞争对手，
比如说Northface,。
这样的品牌的1-1，
或者说Northface本身，
他也不是优衣库的竞队，
因为Northface他面向的是，
更高端的去度假滑雪的人，
但是优衣库要做的，
正是把摇利容，
这种滑雪中产的衣处里，
请到普通人的衣柜里。
这个有点像，
就是IKEA那期我们说的，
民主化设计。
对呀,
民主化设计不容易，
这么便宜的定价，
你的成本要怎么控制，
那还有没有利润？
对呀，那他怎么控制成本呢？
他的做法，
就是直接向中国工厂，
一个无锡的工厂，
下单300万件，
因为定单量大，
所以,
刘景正的谈判一价就高，
而且他还可以，
谈一些其他的条款，
比如说，
不为款的时间，
延后,
一些谈判上的一价吧。
那,
这一批摇利容的，
首单生产成本，
最后做到了，
比预期，
第一百分之四十，
这样的话，
就会为利润留出空间。
但是,
这个定单量，
还有匹配的广告公式，
已经大到，
优衣库账上的资金，
不足以拿下，
所以,
刘景正当年，
是拿出自己的全部，
全部省价，
包括在家族企业里的股份，
还有名下的，
全部房产，
作为底，
跟银行贷款。
所以,
如果当初，
摇利容真的卖不出去，
那,
优衣库就，
资金链断掉的风险，
这个,
这个公赛有没有，
就不知道了。
那,
好堵之后，
优衣库赢来了，
销量省的话，
1998年冬天，
摇利容卖出了两百万件，
到2000年,
摇利容的销量，
达到了两千六百万件，
这是什么概念？
就是四个日本人中，
有一个人就有一件摇利容。
哦，这个，
你讲的这个，
我觉得特别有那种，
日本漫画里那种，
孤注一致，
就很热血的感觉。
对对对，
但这不，
但是这个故事，
到这里并没有结束哦，
神话背后，
马上就是危机，
因为刘景正，
特别看好销量嘛，
所以他决定疯狂增产，
他在自传里面，
那一张就叫大增产，
到2000年,
优衣库，
摇利容的库存，
超过了800万件，
所以他牺牲了一粒润，
那童年消费者也投诉，
摇利容有起求，
甚至是调色的问题，
所以优衣库的治安时刻来了，
2001年,
公司的市值蒸发50%，
品牌形象一落千丈。
那如果是这么说的话，
这算是我刚才说的那种，
就是捅了大楼子类型的了，
因为你看，
98年到2001年，
就大概三年的时间吧，
他这个期期落落，
确实就很抓麻了，
主要是，
就是我听完这个，
会觉得他不像是优衣库这个品牌，
能做出来的事，
因为我以为他是那种，
淡淡的，很轻松，
没有压力的那种，
就跟他的服装是一样的，
感觉的。
优衣库的商业形象，
从来都是和他的产品形象相反，
就是在这次，
治安危机中，
刘景正，
加了一根关键的钢筋，
因为前面不是说嘛，
他说优衣库不是突然变强的，
而是每次，
危机来临之后，
他会加一根钢筋进去嘛，
他就是和面料公司动力合作，
升级了姚丽荣的面料，
解决起球，
还有雕色的问题，
并且推出了高端线。
当然这看起来，
是一次简单的技术升级，
但是,
他奠定了，
后来优衣库的一个关键战略，
就是面料科技，
比如说，
我们现在耳熟能详的Heatac，
刚才你也提到了嘛，
就是什么保暖内裤，保暖内衣，
还有Airism,。
就是夏天来说，
穿的那个西汉内衣，
都是优衣库和东丽联合研制的，
他们俩呢，
也从之前的供应商关系，
变成了共组实验室，
这种更深的绑定关系。
那现在我们再回看，
姚丽荣这个单品，
他早已经成为了，
商业教科书级别的案例，
到2024年,
全球一共卖出了，
是日本人口的三倍多，
他甚至成为了一种文化符号，
日本网友票选，
定义平成时代的三十件物品，
姚丽荣外套排名第七，
就是优衣库的姚丽荣外套排名第七。
那你刚才讲的这个优衣库，
早年的品牌历史，
我觉得，
他正好也合得上一个，
时代发展的主线，
而且换句话说，
其实优衣库现在可以做的这么成功，
它不仅仅的是这个品牌，
做的正确的是，
更重要的是，
它是要卡对时间点，
让品牌和时代相互去成就的。
对，大家其实都知道，
时尚这个概念，
在今天是属于每个人的嘛，
我们可以去关注，去欣赏，
去通过自己的审美，
搭配来参与，
但它并不是一开始就是这样的，
在一战之前，
时尚实际上是一个，
极少数人的权利，
当时的时尚，
它是存在于，
高级定制的，
然后它是给上流社会去定制的，
你的衣服，
帽子，配饰，
与其说是审美的体现，
其实更重要的是，
它是身份的象征，是一种独占符号，
所以当时的服装，
就像一门贵族语言，
普通人是根本没有资格开口的嘛，
然后就是到了二战，
大概在70年来左右，
时尚行业开始进入了成衣革命，
法语它叫Pay Double D,。
就是成衣，
然后那个时候，
设计师的成衣，
才第一次的进入到中产的医出当中，
然后时尚也是逐渐从，
原先的那个富人，
或者说上层阶级的独占，
然后开始民主化和普及，
就可以说这个是时尚，
第一次分蛋糕，
主要上切下来一块，
然后去和中产阶级先去开始分享。
就是对应优衣库的历史也确实，
像刘景正和爸爸，
他那个西装店，
其实就是这个阶段的产物，
因为他的受众是银行职员，
就是典型的中产。
对，所以你看我们现在所熟知的这个优衣库，
其实很难在，
我刚才说的那两个阶段成型的，
你没法想象，
那怎么会有什么服装大仓，
然后每个人都是，
所以我们是需要去，
这个品牌也是到了，
1990年2000年左右，
他才可能出现，
因为那个时候开始有全球零售，
然后也会出现这种，
所谓的愚法型的品牌，
然后GAP开始开连锁店，
所以也就是那个时候，
才能有我们现在认为的这个优衣库。
我们也是时代的参与者，
就是优衣库，
确实是在1999年上市，
2000年之后的优衣库，
它的扩张制度肯定是持续的，
尤其在全球化这个层面，
我在纽约搜索的优衣库，
扣误过，
好几层楼的旗舰店，
气势绝对不输，
那条大道上的，
一众欧美品牌。
那Jacky你在巴黎的这些年，
能够感觉到优衣库的CLA变化吗？
你这么一问的话，
我还真的记得优衣库，
就是最最开始，
那几年在法国的样子，
所以也算是
见证了优衣库的海外扩张了吧，
因为当时国内其实，
优衣库已经非常非常多了，
就很多城市，各个城市都有，
就是你想买优衣库是，
相对来讲是比较方便的，
但是在欧洲，
就是我们印象当中，
这么时尚的这些国家里，
其实优衣库非常非常少，
我记得他当年在地铁里打广告，
就是还不是巴黎地铁站那种，
整面墙的大广告，
他就是一个长条，
然后在地铁的车厢里，
那个时候应该是刚刚开始，
尝试欧洲市场，
不过，他的旗舰店，
其实一开始，
就开在非常非常好的地段，
就是巴黎的各区院旁边，
老佛耶百货的对面，
而且开的还挺大的，
可能在远一点的地方还有，
但是离我都不是特别方便了，
然后过了几年之后，
就是我持续地在买优衣库，
但是我没有特意地去在关注我这个品牌，
然后就发现不知不觉当中，
优衣库的门店，
就是在巴黎就开了，
就是更多了，
而且会感觉到，
他的那个文化变得很强，
就比如说，
在马黑区的店，
他是在一个十八世纪的老建筑里，
然后装修后呢，
一部分建筑的结构，
还是保留了下来，
然后甚至地下呢，
有一块地方，
就隔着那个玻璃，
还放着老的那种机械，
不知道是干什么用的，
应该是在优衣库进来之前，
他前身会用到的一些东西，
就是有一种历史感，
然后呢，就是品牌联名，
然后潮流合作款，
还有一些日本文化的东西，
然后包括和当地的联名，
像卢福公联名系列之类的，
总之就是感觉，
时间过得很快，
然后不知不觉当中，
优衣库就从那个，
出来炸到闯江湖的那个形象，
变成了相当有存在感的那种大宗门，
能感觉出来，
就是在你的描述中，
听得到，
优衣库在法国是越搬越好了，
法国市场其实是有点特异性的，
他在首年就实现了盈利，
像纽约市场，
他是在四年之后，
实现了盈利，
然后在伦敦市场，
头两年是大惨败，
当初刘景正这个创始人，
他决定出海的时候，
当时就在考虑是去纽约，
巴黎还是伦敦这三个地方，
结果他一开始，
首战选的是伦敦，
因为他是用排除法做的，
他觉得纽约，
他觉得自己实力还不到，
不知道能不能拿下，
然后巴黎，
他觉得，
巴黎人是有这种，
设计上先天的优越感的，
会比较排外，
所以他最后排除法下来去了伦敦，
但实战下来没想到，
没想到，
巴黎其实是表现最好的，
第一年就出现了盈利，
就是他和巴黎还挺有缘的，
我觉得他在巴黎面前，
完全不需要有这种自卑心态，
因为他难道不知道，
法国人有多喜欢日本人这件事吗，
法国人真的非常喜欢日本文化，
而且,
可能因为日本文化，
怎么说呢，
他进入到欧洲是比较早的，
然后通过一些，
所谓的艺术品，
像扶持会，瓷器，
然后饮食，合服，
这种东西，
然后到后来的电影，
什么的，
就其实，
就法国，
已经非常吃日式的那种，
生活哲学，
或者一些理念的东西了，
但是,
但是优越库他本身，
也不是很日式，
优越库他本身，
其实是有点去封华的，
就不知道，
就是,
法国人会认为，
这是一种日式风格吗，
他在法国，
其实还是会打日式的牌，
可能现在，
不是特别明显了吧，
除了一些模特，
什么的那种，
他有穿搭风格，
就是他可能会有点，
亲日,
或者说他会挑，
法国人喜欢的那一套，
最靠近日本的，
去表达，
就是法国人，
其实是对日本有Fantasy的，
他当时，
应该是，
没预料的，
因为他自占你用的原话，
是觉得法国还是比较自负的，
他这个判断也没错的，
但是法国人，
其实还是挺，
平民的，
就是生活还是比较，
日常的那种，
我觉得反而比日本的，
就比英国跟，
美国要更，
生活化，
更平民化，
确实,
就是,
今儿我们也聊到一个，
很关键的话题，
就是,
欧美市场，
因为,
欧美市场对优越库，
有着特殊的意义，
因为他们属于，
这种设计一家市场，
他们本质上，
不太能，
接受无聊，
但是,
优越库又擅长，
做等基础款嘛，
那,
优越库在2000年之后，
他陆去出海欧美，
在2006年,
在纽约搜索区，
开出旗舰店，
但是,
前四年，
都是亏损的状态，
我觉得我还挺配不这个，
创始人的，
能够忍了四年，
对,
然后到了2009年，
纽约旗舰店的销量，
主要是靠它的功能，
我们刚才提到那个故事嘛，
就是HITAC,。
这个保暖系列，
来支撑，
但是它的时尚类单品，
其实表现都不太好，
甚至在日本本土，
年轻消费者，
也开始厌倦国民制服，
像优越库的基础款，
这种纯色的T恤，
牛仔裤，
都被视为是上班族的标配，
年轻人甚至会觉得，
穿优越库，
就等于放弃个性，
那,
这两方面嘛，
一来是本土用户的审美疲劳，
另外就是，
欧美这种，
设计一家市场的倒逼，
让优越库开始，
加注一根新的钢筋，
就是我们下面要聊到的，
借力国际设计师，
2009年,
这个也是比较标志型的一个事件，
优越库和德国的集结女王，
只有Sander合作，
推出了我们现在，
更熟悉的优越库，
加这系列，
对,
我觉得优越库在合作时候，
选择设计师，
真的是非常精准的，
像我们刚才比喻的这种，
语法型品牌，
它其实并不是平价的品牌，
才会去做的，
反而会集中，
在中高端和设计师品牌当中，
比较常见，
我觉得，
就像Lemel,。
还有The Row,。
还有刚才，
会是提到的那个Joe Sander，
而且,
我们会发现，
其实Lemel和Joe Sander,。
后来还真的都和优越库有过cross，
那种最纯粹的，
语法型设计师，
最后都和优越库产生交集，
我觉得还挺妙的，
所以这也是，
优越库，
它最聪明的地方，
它去主动找同样坚持，
语法的人去合作，
像Lemel和Joe Sander,。
他们在时尚领域，
其实语法的那种，
怎么说呢，
高度一致，
和稳定是很有口碑的，
然后优越库，
通过和他们去合作，
实际上，
就是可以去补全自己的语法库，
然后也在用设计师品牌，
就是来背书证明，
说,
你看,
语法型不等于无聊，
就优越库的基础款，
不等于，
就是说过时，
没有性格，
这个样子，
能够看出来，
直击了当初的痛点，
其实日本本土的人，
会觉得，
有点无聊嘛，
所以就在那之后，
优越库也算尝到了甜头，
在2010年,
就刚才说了嘛，
2009年的开舍这个合作，
在2010年,
转过年来，
就把这种零星的合作，
转向了战略的绑定，
它在东京，
巴黎,
纽约,
三个城市，
都成立了，
设计研发中心，
可以系统性的对接设计师，
那再转过年来，
它就推出了，
每年两季的，
常态化联名，
那这个，
就是我们，
现在熟悉的，
优越库版本了，
就是,
光平时可以买它，
每年还会有个小小的期待，
给今年的设计师，
款有什么小惊喜，
咱能不能，
花小钱，
办大事，
这种事，
对对对，
你说的这种，
真的是让我印象深刻，
我记得大概是，
2015年,
还是16年吧，
就当时广告里，
我看到，
就是优越库，
在和冷卖我做联名，
然后就觉得，
哇，就是很惊喜，
因为当时刚，
刚毕业嘛，
就根本不舍得，
去买了麦克，
就本品牌的衣服，
所以就特意跑到，
这个优越库的门店，
去试,
去的时候，
就很多，
就其实都已经都没货，
就被,
被巴黎人给抢光了那种，
然后还包括，
后面,
它和那个，
J.W. Anderson的联名,。
我其实也挺喜欢的，
就,
对，买过几件，
然后我会觉得，
他们的这种合作，
不是扶予表面的贴牌，
就你不会质疑，
说这些联名品牌，
它是不是本来，
自己价格高，
然后所以它通过，
跟这种大众品牌合作，
去割韭菜，
就它,
你不会给人这种感觉，
而且,
嗯,
很神奇的是，
优越库做的这些款，
你会觉得，
它和联名品牌，
确实有一种一致的感觉，
但是它本身，
你当看它，
它又是优越库，
它还是优越库，
对,
然后价格，
甚至也还是优越库，
我觉得，
这就是一个，
两边,
都增加好感的一个操作，
就是,
你知道这一点，
大家都觉得满意，
这个我觉得，
我建议你去听听，
设计师的吐槽，
就是,
蓝麦奥在，
蓝麦奥的设计师，
在杂志反弹中，
提到过优越库，
他说,
他们给了我，
一本五百页的技术手册，
告诉我，
什么能做，
什么不能做，
对对对，
你知道，
你说的这个情况，
其实我朋友也遇到过，
就是一开始，
我说那个，
我们在巴黎的，
某品牌工作的，
对，他说，
他们品牌的日本客人，
也是这样的，
就是特别扣戏级，
而且有点那种，
控制框的感觉，
确实,
就是这一期我们，
因为时间限制没有讲，
优越库就对于，
版型的这种，
惊喜度，
这个是，
真的是高景度，
就包括，
刘景正自己也说过，
当时他不是试图模仿Zara吗，
他说,
Zara是西班牙的热血，
但是我们人，
我们日本人，
其实,
更擅长的是一种，
客制和精密，
就是再说回来，
就是,
优越库的设计师款，
还有一点做得很好，
就是除了自己，
表现出色，
还会反补基础款，
比如说，
一些检查方式，
就会被基础款吸纳，
可以说，
设计师款，
整体把，
优越库的天花板，
给太高了，
这个也是，
为什么，
就我们隐隐的觉得，
优越库一直在进化，
不知不觉中，
他好像又好了一点，
那你刚才说，
就是你看到，
优越库的变化，
就是你觉得，
他们卖的衣服，
在法国有什么变化吗？
其实不大，
因为从，
优越库进入到，
法国之后，
已经很快就，
出现那个，
联名款了嘛，
而且,
很奇怪的是，
我在法国，
只要进优越库，
我绝对能，
买出东西来，
但是,
如果在国内的话，
我其实不太容易，
买出东西来，
会是,
优越库本身的区别，
或者说，
能够看到，
更多的设计师款嘛，
但是,
在国内还是，
以基础款为主。
其实,
我觉得应该不是，
应该是，
跟他的那个，
陈社有关，
就是,
这边的陈社，
可能做的，
更不像是，
那种,
嗯,
随便逛个商场，
然后,
穿饭,
溜一下的那种卖场，
他真的还是会有，
不计,
就是那种，
品牌的，
专营店，
或旗舰店的感觉，
嗯,
不一样，
总去了优越库，
其实是我们家，
附近的一个，
就是,
类似于商场吧，
但他也不是那种，
大商场，
然后他在地下一楼，
就感觉跟逛个超市，
没什么区别，
就那种，
就是大仓，
也没有小仓，
嗯,
但是那种旗舰店，
给人的感觉，
还是不一样的，
他是那种铺面儿来的，
你觉得他是，
成体系的，
推到你面前的，
其实,
优越库最早的时候，
他,
主要打的，
就是一个，
他有点像，
农村包围城市，
关东,
看到东京的时候，
是非常紧张的，
他很多年都没敢去，
他一直是在这种，
郊外，小地方，
包括就是，
这个创始人本人，
他也是一个，
小地方出来的人，
而且当时，
在东京也是，
才学到了一点，
觉得,
哦，东京人，
他不会随便出手，
买东西，
而且他没有那么看重价钱，
没有那么看重性价比，
就是你的东西必须要好，
所以他也是，
一步一步走来的，
所以他，
就是,
可以真的是说，
是从草根，
从平民，
走向了一个国际大牌，
那,
那所以就是，
这个就是为什么，
我觉得，
现在,
我们还是能，
就是像我家门口，
还有这种，
觉得是随便逛，
跟逛烧吃，
也没啥区别的这种店，
但同时，
他也会有那种，
全球旗舰店，
就是上海的那个旗舰店，
有两家，
做的也挺好的，
就是,
好几层，
哦,
你觉得，
他真的是在精心布置，
甚至还会卖花，
我觉得，
他这个，
就是你说，
农村包围城市，
这库是有比较大的助力的，
因为大部分，
我们只要一提到石上，
就哪怕像，
我们刚才举例子的，
Cost,
Zara,
这种,
快市上，
就是比较平价的品牌，
他还是，
姿态,
就是一直手势，
要扒到石上这件事儿的，
但Yoyko,
他是从底下一步，
往上走的，
所以他其实，
还蛮能抓住，
大众的那个，
购买的心态，
然后还有就是，
刚才,
就是我们说，
这个门店之间的差异嘛，
比如说，
我刚才提到的那个，
马黑区的那家店，
这个东西是，
商场给不了你了，
然后,
你再要加持一些，
比如说，
每个,
我不知道他是不是有，
每个店的店长的那个，
权限有多大，
然后搭配师，
就是可能，
换一个地方，
就会有一个，
差别,
他这个店长的那个，
话语学应该是不小的，
因为,
他在他的自传中，
一直说嘛，
就是Yoyko的核心是卖场，
然后卖场的核心是店长，
所以他这里面的，
这种方差值，
应该是非常大的，
而Yoyko的店实在是太多了，
他早期是那种，
加盟店，
这一面想象，
就是,
这个核，
他创始人的这个，
做生意的理念，
他的生意精致有关系的，
因为他认为，
如果你要想拿下一个区域，
你什么时候开始盈利，
当你开了足够的店的数量的时候，
比如说，
几百个的时候，
这个时候，
你就会形成这种，
压倒性的优势。
他其实，
可能创始人本质，
他是一个生意人，
他不是一个，
设计师，
或者说，
宣传主导的，
这种感觉，
他是,
就是一个纯生意人，
然后,
所以就是，
我记得你之前，
跟我说，
就是，你觉得Yoyko，
其实特别的功课，
对对对，
对,
因为他是，
提供生活的解决方案嘛，
他认为服装是工具，
人是主角，
然后服装是配角，
所以他从来没有想说，
我一定要到设计领域，
就做到如何如何，
或者说，
我这个东西如何抢劲，
他提供解决方案啊，
跟,
跟比如说，
从他去写代码，
他也做的是解决方案，
就是那种理工感，
铺面而来，
嗯,
好啦,
我们刚才讲了，
Yoyko的几个关键节点，
现在在回望，
Jacky刚才提的那个问题，
就是,
Yoyko是如何造系统，
造与发的，
然后,
我们可能就有一个大致的轮廓了，
对,
反正,
聊到现在，
我会觉得，
Yoyko他作为一个品牌，
他,
做到的，
其实不是无差别的，
去照顾所有人，
这个就太，
怎么说，
理想主义了，
几乎是不可能实现的，
一个口号型的，
一个东西，
就,
所以说，
Yoyko他就打磨出了，
另外一套逻辑，
他一点一点的，
去建立一套，
宽容度极高的规则，
就是,
无论你懂不懂时尚，
或者在哪个文化环境里，
都不会被排斥在外，
然后,
至于你想要，
进去多深，
达到什么样的效果，
就有因人而易了，
就比如说，
呃,
不是一个非常厉害的，
穿搭博主，
但是不妨碍我，
进入到Yoyko，
去解决我的一些需求，
而等我有一天，
如果想要，
穿出自己的神媒，
自己的风格的时候，
我还是可以走进Yoyko，
他还是能，
无差别的去迎接我，
嗯,
对,
无差别的迎接我们，
所以我们每年，
还会有那样的，
一个小期待，对吧，
他又出了什么新款，
然后对我来讲，
也是,
对,
我已经反复回购，
他的Aryism内衣，
非常多次了，
就不停的去，
呃,
就再次光临Yoyko，
可能会，
因为他的功能型，
而再次，
进入他的门店，
有可能是，
怀着一份期待，
希望我能够，
花小钱，
办大事，
是吧,
好了,
这一期就是这样，
也欢迎，
听有给我们留言，
就大家可以讨论一下，
你最喜欢，
Yoyko的哪个系列，
呃,
是不是这一系列，
又系列，
或者是基础款呢，
好了,
那这期就这样，
我们下期见，
拜拜,